[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
i've got something quite a bit different
for you guys as we're going to be diving
into a segment from the autobiography of
jk rowling published over a decade ago
on her old website where she discusses
the struggles she faced in life as she
wrote the first harry potter novel among
many other things we find out how she
chose the name potter who the chamber of
secrets was dedicated to
how the book nearly failed completion
and how the book was eventually
published let's get into it
my mother and father were both londoners
they met on a train traveling from
king's cross station to arboreth in
scotland when they were both 18. my
father was off to join the royal navy my
mother to join the wrns
the women's equivalent
my mother said she was cold
my father offered her a half share in
his coat and they got married just over
a year later when they were 19.
both left the navy and moved to the
outskirts of bristol
in the west of england
my mother gave birth to me when she was
20. i was a rotund baby the description
in the philosopher's stone of the
photographs of what appeared to be a
beach ball wearing different coloured
bobble hats would also apply to the
pictures of my early years
my sister dee arrived a year and 11
months after me
the day of her birth is my earliest
memory or my earliest dateable memory
anyway i distinctly remember playing
with a bit of plasticine in the kitchen
while my father rushed in and out of the
room hurrying backwards and forwards to
my mother who was giving birth in their
bedroom
i know i didn't invent this memory
because i checked the details later with
my mother i also have a vivid mental
picture of walking into their bedroom a
little while later
hand in hand with my father and seeing
my mother lying in bed in her night
dress next to my beaming sister who is
stark naked with a full head of hair and
looks about five years old although i
clearly pasted together this bizarre
false memory out of bits of hearsay when
i was a child
it is so vivid that it still comes to
mind if i ever think about dee being
born
dee had and still has very dark almost
black hair and dark brown eyes like my
mother's and she was considerably
prettier than i was and she still is
as compensation i think my parents
decided that i must be the bright one
we both resented our labels
i really wanted to be less frankly beach
ball like andy who is now a lawyer
felt justifiably annoyed that nobody had
noticed she was not just a pretty face
this undoubtedly contributed to the fact
that we spent about three quarters of
our childhood fighting like a pair of
wild cats imprisoned together in a very
small cage
to this day dee bears a tiny scar just
above her eyebrow from the cut i gave
her when i threw a battery at her but i
didn't expect it to hit her i thought
she'd duck
this excuse didn't cut much ice with my
mother who was angrier than i had ever
seen her we left the bungalow when i was
four and moved to winterbourne also on
the outskirts of bristol
now we lived in a semi-detached house
with stairs which prompted dee and i to
reenact over and over again a cliff-top
drama in which one of us would dangle
from the topmost stair
holding hands with the other and
pleading with them not to let go
offering all manner of bribery and
blackmail until falling to their death
we found this endlessly amusing i think
the last time we played the cliff game
was two christmases to go my
nine-year-old daughter didn't find it
nearly as funny as we did
the small amount of time that we didn't
spend fighting dee and i were best
friends
i told her a lot of stories and
sometimes didn't even have to sit on her
to make a stay and listen
often the stories became games in which
we both played regular characters i was
extremely bossy when i stage managed
these long-running plays but dee put up
with it because i usually gave her star
parts
there were lots of children around our
age living in our new street among them
a brother and sister whose surname was
potter
i always liked their name whereas i
wasn't very fond of my own
rolling the first syllable of which is
pronounced row as in boat rather than
rao as an argument
lent itself to willful jokes such as
rolling stone rolling pin and so on
anyway the brother has since cropped up
in the press claiming to be harry
his mother also told reporters that he
and i used to dress up as wizards
neither of these claims is true in fact
all i remember of the boy in question
was that he rode a chopper which was the
bicycle everybody wanted in the 70s and
once threw a stone at d
for which i hit him hard over the head
with a plastic sword i was the only one
allowed to throw things at d
i enjoyed school in winterbourne it was
a very relaxed environment i remember
lots of pottery making drawing and story
writing which suited me perfectly
however my parents had always harbored a
dream of living in the country
and around my ninth birthday we moved
for the last time to tuchel a small
village just outside chepstow in wales
the move coincided almost exactly the
death of my favorite grandparent
kathleen whose name i later took when i
needed an extra initial
no doubt the first bereavement of my
life influenced my feelings about my new
school which i didn't like at all
we sat all day at roll top desks facing
the blackboard there were old inkwells
set into the desktops
there was a second hole in my desk which
had been gouged out with the point of a
compass by the boy who had sat there the
year before
he had obviously worked away quietly out
of the sight of the teacher
i thought this was a great achievement
and set to work enlarging the hole with
my own compass so that by the time i
left that classroom you could
comfortably wiggle your thumb through it
my secondary school weidin where i went
when i was 11 was the place i met sean
harris to whom chamber of secrets is
dedicated and who owned the original
ford anglia he was the first of my
friends to learn to drive and that
turquoise and white car meant freedom
and no more having to ask my father to
give me lifts which is the worst thing
about living in the countryside when
you're a teenager
some of the happiest memories of my
teenage years involved zooming off into
the darkness in sean's car he was the
first person with whom i really
discussed my serious ambition to be a
writer and he was also the only person
who thought i was bound to be a success
at it which meant much more to me than i
ever told him at the time
the worst thing that happened during my
teenage years was my mother becoming ill
she was diagnosed with multiple
sclerosis which is a disease of the
central nervous system when i was 15.
although most people with multiple
sclerosis experience periods of
remission when their illness stops
progressing for a while or even improves
mum was unlucky from the time of her
diagnosis onwards she seemed to become
slowly but steadily worse
i think most people believe deep down
that their mothers are indestructible it
was a terrible shock to hear that she
had an incurable illness
but even then i did not fully realize
what the diagnosis might mean
i left school in 1983 and went to study
at the university of exeter on the south
coast of england i studied french which
was a mistake i'd succumbed to parental
pressure to study useful modern
languages
as opposed to but where will it lead
english and really should have stood my
ground
on the plus side studying french meant
that i had a year living in paris as
part of my course
after leaving university i worked in
london
my longest job was with amnesty
international the organization that
campaigns against human rights abusers
all over the world
but in 1990 my then boyfriend and i
decided to move up to manchester
together it was after a weekend's flat
hunting when i was traveling back to
london on my own on a crowded train that
the idea for harry potter simply fell
into my head
i had been writing almost continuously
since the age of six
but i had never been so excited about an
idea before
to my immense frustration i didn't have
a functioning pen with me i was too shy
to ask anybody if i could borrow one
i think now that this was probably a
good thing because i simply sat and
thought for four delayed train hours and
all the details bubbled up in my brain
and this scrawny blackhead bespectacled
boy who didn't know he was a wizard
became more and more real to me i think
that perhaps if i had to slow down the
ideas so that i could capture them on
paper i might have stifled some of them
although sometimes i do wonder widely
how much of what i imagined on that
journey i had forgotten by the time i
actually got my hands on a pen i began
to write philosopher's stone that very
evening although those first few pages
bear no resemblance at all to anything
in the finished book
i moved up to manchester taking the
swelling manuscript with me which was
now growing in all sorts of strange
directions and including ideas for the
rest of harry's career at hogwarts not
just his first year
then on december 30th 1990
something happened that changed both my
world and harry's forever
my mother died it was a terrible time my
father dee and i were devastated she was
only 45 years old and we had ever
imagined probably because we could not
bear to contemplate the idea that she
could die so young
i remember feeling as though there was a
paving slab pressing down upon my chest
a literal pain in my heart
nine months later desperate to get away
for a while i left for portugal where i
had got a job teaching english in a
language institute i took with me the
still-growing manuscript of harry potter
hopeful that my new working hours i
taught in the afternoon and evening
would lend themselves to pressing on
with my novel which had changed a lot
since my mother had died
now harry's feelings about his dead
parents have become much deeper
much more real
in my first weeks in portugal i wrote my
favorite chapter in philosopher's stone
the mirror of erised
i had hoped that when i returned from
portugal i would have a finished book
under my arm
in fact i had something even better my
daughter
i had met and married a portuguese man
and although the marriage did not work
out it had given me the best thing in my
life
jessica and i arrived in edinburgh where
my sister dee was living just in time
for christmas 1993
i intended to start teaching again and
knew that unless i finished the book
very soon i might never finish it i knew
that full-time teaching with all the
marking and lesson planning let alone
with a small daughter to care for
single-handedly
would leave me with absolutely no spare
time at all
and so i set to work in a kind of frenzy
determined to finish the book and at
least try and get it published
whenever jessica fell asleep in her push
chair i would dash to the nearest cafe
and write like mad
i wrote nearly every evening
then i had to type the whole thing out
myself sometimes i actually hated the
book even while i loved it
finally it was done i covered the first
three chapters in a nice plastic folder
and set them off to an agent who
returned them so fast they must have
been sent back the same day they arrived
but the second agent i tried wrote back
and asked to see the rest of the
manuscript it was far and away the best
letter i had ever received in my life
and it was only two sentences long it
took a year for my new agent christopher
to find a publisher
lots of them turned it down
then finally in august 1996
christopher telephoned me and told me
that bloomsbury had made an offer
i could not quite believe my ears you
mean it's going to be published i asked
rather stupidly it's definitely going to
be published after i'd hung up i
screamed and jumped into the air jessica
who was sitting in a high chair enjoying
tea
looked thoroughly scared
and you probably know what happened next
i hope you guys enjoyed that little
piece of harry potter history and if you
have anything to add
please leave a comment down below
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you